profesor gracias por estar con nosotros
buen día lo que ha ocurrido de la
votación anticipada este año supera ya
por millones al total registrado en 2016
que lecturas se le puede dar a esta
información ya que se debe que más
personas estén interesadas en votar
buenos dias raúl así es la gente ha
acudido a las urnas hay mucho interés en
la votación de este año y esto se puede
ver con la votación anticipada que como
bien indicas es mucho mayor ya a la que
se dio en su totalidad en 2016 a pesar
de que todavía falta más de una semana
así que vamos a tener que entre 30 y 50
por ciento de los votantes van a haber
votado antes de la oficial en la
elección que es el martes 3 de noviembre
profesor los sondeos le dan la ventaja
al demócrata joe biden estas cifras a
favor de biden se podrían interpretar ya
como una proyección para el día de las
elecciones
pues si las encuestas le dan el favor al
candidato va a ir en del partido
demócrata y sobre todo en estados claves
hay un margen de error sin embargo en
muchos de los estados el margen de
negarles la ventaja que tiene bailén es
de más de 78 9% así que hay 17 confianza
de que estos estén conteos esos sondeos
tienen cierta validez claro esto va a
depender de la gente que de hecho vaya a
hipótesis que no sabremos el resultado
final hasta el día de la elección pero
si él pinta bien para baile ahora cómo
quedan las denuncias que ha realizado el
presidente donald trump sobre el posible
fraude que se puede cometer en estas
votaciones por correo al parecer la
población si confía en esta modalidad de
voto
así es en eeuu hay mucha confianza en el
sistema de correo público la gente puede
votar por correo muy pocos de los de los
votos se pierden sin embargo ahora con
estas dudas que ha levantado trump mucha
gente se está presentando a votar
adelantadamente pero en persona para
evitar este posible retraso en el correo
la gente está votando cuando en los
estados que se pueden en persona